on avait faim on av'ait pas d'argent
pour manger quand jamaiselle en avait
euh il se payait une crêpe et on la
partageait quoi en trois je sais pas ce
que j'ai fait dans ma vie pour avoir la
chance de croiser des gens vraiment qui
ont changé ma vie que ce soit ERC Judor
ou Jamel de Bou ces gens ont changé ma
vie c'est fou j'ai énormément de chance
d'avoir d'avoir ces gens dans ma vie ça
fait 30 ans et je les ai encore
aujourd'hui
j'ai c'est vraiment des mecs super on
est dans la fraternité dans une vraie
fraternité je me souviens avec Jamel et
Eric il y a 30 ans on on payait
l'essence à Jamel pour qu'il vienneent
de trappe pour qu'il viennent faire des
auditions on gardait 5 francs 10 francs
pour payer l'essence on se partageait
des crêpes à à 10 balles on avait faim
on avait pas d'argent pour manger quand
jamaiselle en avait euh il se payait une
crêpe et on la partageait quoi en trois
c'est fou